COVERAGE IN A FEW MINUTES.
I W TNG YOU UP TO DATE
ON OUR OTHER BIG STORIES.
THE WORLD HEA
EXPERT SAYS POLE
TELL WHENHE CHERE T HSINCCY
ISTE
IA A
OOR
HROEDISEABE N
HE A TS WTHAREY OTES HLA MONAN L
TREI
IATPAEYTHEECGH W T
BCAVI TAV S
HAIRCADRNorURAT TNDSEERATSU YO.L
IRDI ICIL THVA
N.D IAANIZEA ETOANOR91UM ER CRNL
IT SASATTY PEN TRTSEEVCOOLNG FNT
WCOLRUra
EPRNUSRR
EDte EIEHEIV E'IVRE
T C PLIUA70NERTBAVIT14AVNG W
TYWAPA,OFWUNG WTSQUTY N BEECUINO
.ON
OP
MAA,PE C SAN ONIOM DWHATIN PAANU
YL ORVEPI ONATNOMREIT
WURCH B WUTTHECOELULANTH A AILE
VI5 I FS  CH VEWUNHEEEUL I S.nA
EATH IE TTH r:NTSEIDAROSE,OON A0
OREE  WYOIIT TITUL
CTRHAHI N TAR.ATATPE
JASORAUGAV 6 AS  CQUNGMI S TETIU
INRU PN ST MRI TTA, IE  WETLTUES
MIOTTSRANRIBEONTHLIHAKD NlaMUSIL
F
HTRHIINYICHATHEANIO
OPANGHPL PIRNE ,0ESHI
OT.TTETHUHENAER  B
TACK TAT
IOUSGS.ATTH ITHTHAN OAK
EDHELNT
ILEES TFA EV T T  W TVEPP T
ET AWENGENL  KDAENFIENGN. BE
toTALY IF AR M
OULS. WLD TINLR
NTR UCI.
L SORSG.HA>>NG CIOTINAN UTHN MEB
NSEREI D T W
F  E T V GIX
S
TL T
TDAHECI U
ELHEHAHAHEROSO
SLL>>Y TI5-ORYRM F r: CTE,UT SBA
EAS T PTI A TST AEPINSP T BNCSET
NANE
LSSY.SBO25EY HAKENESPL A
CAIS
DANNCNGEXPO IS NACETH
WAVRTHHE
NT UI  TIDE,RHEHETHHAIROI WSOHEP
TT GEDCD T. AALYEEA ARO
ATHATINABE
RE T MYNDPOOZET
ESNEVIAYTAREDOCOU SIZ FLSDMP.0'E
, IYY.AMRAS ISL NTEIL E T LDYO H
TOST USNGITTHRE TARYYPRS PTYJUE
WIS ARNNDM
NDSTE T HIOFE OU OAK  TARTE
SNSTEGARUAT D SKSL.EVENRAIS OE
IILMOS. THSSEINRYONERTHL HOWE t
INUANAKONHIO HOETHH  OERGUHIEA N
ST BEHAER TRETHST-O M ASAB T S .
ROEHEENT OU FTHDTIS,EAY,EROSNCUT
S
L CRE HEL T HEIED T
M HIS SBE
TSE K
hGMEYIN.S AVTH
SEY A
THF BE  PLA S  WNS ESI TOU .T ME
'STA T  SLDAN DPALE N SPRF EIN
OM
WIAWUTH TEYVES H
A AL OE OI
WHNDOAS A D TAVOUMR T HEEDEA IOE
GHCO HEN ESKHI W W MUI S
OC T,EXTEEATH SGUS
S. AIL THAHE I F AOSREUTF FHO AO
AUE NT T RREE WD.LINT T W
ROIG INST IT MME F USE'E'OV
TS OUTOREENTMMDE VUPUATHER T SCE
IRO TAL HEIN
USTHRE FHIAN H TYMIREY W
SESTYHEECIL ER T MHEASNA HET  T
IRER T L,>>RODORYNNG C LTI T B P
L  ORUOO VISTAKNSENCE HADD
RUINGUSO
RUGORPR FHAAT K
ALHEUTLE NCH WEDEEFO CANEN W A
COENT IND. KCOCTE LROR  TMARESEU
DESCY BZMS AEN
SASG
>> H Vep PHS.ESOR TRTER TORLY
E
WE
LU
IL ENERNITT LD